back when sukuna was in his prime over
1,000 years ago he had an ultimate form
with four arms but when he possesses
Yuji and then later megumi in the
present time he doesn't use that form
for a long time fans have been wondering
why sukuna hasn't returned to the for
armed form and in my Jutsu kaisen videos
I've been saying that the modern day
sukuna is not at full power and that
when he does reach his full power he
will unlock the forearmed form again
well chapter 237 of the manga gave us
sukuna ultimate transformation in the
present time time with the help of a
cursed tool sukuna was able to transform
into his ultimate for armed form
essentially he resumed his
transformation as a curse that is taking
fleshly form and this allowed him to
heal his damaged body without using his
exhausted reserves of reverse curse
technique this means that sukuna is now
once again at full power if you want to
be the first to find out what happens
next subscribe to anime opo right now